omega diese gewürze einen arabischen
küche die ist einfach mega du hast hast
du und direkt ins boot
[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es schicken
bilder also hähnchen bibiani das ist ein
extrem leckeres hauptgericht es gibt
gewürz reis mit richtig lecker gewürztem
hähnchen und das ganze richtig schön
zart das ist ein sehr beliebtes rezept
und es gibt wahrscheinlich auch ganz
viele verschiedene varianten
ich zeige euch hier meine variante die
ihr wirklich ganz ganz einfach schritt
für schritt nach machen können es ist so
ein bisschen was die gewürze angeht
vielleicht für manche außerhalb der
komfortzone man braucht vielleicht
einfach mal auch neue gewürze aber es
wird sich lohnen also vertraut macht das
wirklich eins zu eins nach die schreibe
euch wie immer alle ganz genauen
mengenangaben unten in die video
beschreibung also unten in die infobox
und ich starte jetzt einfach schon mal
mit meinen zwiebeln und da habe ich euch
einen reingeschrieben entweder nimmt der
normale zwiebeln oder in dem die roten
um euch das zu demonstrieren haben jetzt
einfach noch eine rote mit dazu genommen
das ist also ich hier nicht wichtig die
werde ich jetzt erst mal fein schneiden
und dann kümmere ich mich so ein
bisschen darum die tomaten auch schon
mal zu hacken was sie aber auch schon
vorbereiten könnt ist das ihr den reis
ist schön unter lauwarm oder kaltem
wasser ein bisschen aus spült das heißt
ihr spielt so ein bisschen die stärke
aus das wasser wirklich komplett klar
aber es wird auf jeden fall viel viel
klarer und das kennt er schon so von
meinen reisgerichten dann wird halt
einfach super locker und klebt nicht und
dann den reis einfach nochmal in
lauwarmes wasser legen und 20 minuten
stehen dass das könnte hält super
vorbereiten damit ihr gleich nicht auf
den reis warten müsst ich gehe jetzt los
und schnäbel mein gemüse damit geht es
weiter
[Musik]
so ich habe jetzt schon mal etwas
sonnenblumenöl in einen großen topf
gegeben und die zwiebeln dazu getan und
jetzt sind sie ungefähr drei minuten
vergangen man merkt dass wir dann auch
so einfallen bei anderen gerichten würde
ich jetzt vielleicht weitermachen bei
dem gericht dauert es aber noch so
sieben acht minuten und jetzt gebe ich
auch zucker dazu dass karamellisiert
dann nämlich schön bin ja bei stufe
sieben von neun und dann brauchst jetzt
bei mir noch weitere fünf minuten wie
gesagt lasst euch da ganz viel zeit
nebenbei hatte ich ja schon mal die
tomaten fein das ist hier das läuft ja
alles ganz entspannt ab gerade und zeige
ich euch gleich weitergeht
[Musik]
so die zwiebeln sind soweit und ich habe
jetzt hier rischen ingwer und knoblauch
10 und jetzt nehme ich mir auch meine
feinen reibe und gibt das quasi direkt
mit in den topf und
danach kommen auch schon die gewürze
dazu da sind wie gesagt heute so ein
paar exotische gewürze aber ihr müsst
auch manchmal falls ist jetzt nicht
gewohnt seien die dinge würden zu kochen
einfach mal raus aus der komfortzone
dann habt ihr sie da und dann könnt ihr
sie hat immer wieder benutzen
[Musik]
anschließend geht es direkt weiter mit
denen du würzen es kommt karl amon cups
denn dazu eine zimtstange und
kreuzkümmel kurkuma und gar am us dollar
falls er zum beispiel mein gast ihr
müsst ihr durch meine gewürze verwenden
falls sie schon welche da habt nehmt sie
gerne schaut man auf die rückseite was
für zutaten drin sind in meinem kader
massa ist schon zittrig aber weil ich
diese zimt note einfach lieber habe ich
jetzt zusätzlich noch eine zimtstange
mit dazu getan und durch die röstaromen
durch das rösten kommt entfaltet es halt
noch mal so richtig das aroma und jetzt
gerade riecht es auch schon extrem gut
wir machen jetzt folgendes dass es
könnte jetzt hier nochmal grad so eine
minute so ein bisschen die aromen
entfalten und jetzt geben wir butter g
dazu das ist butter schmalz und das ist
das original arabische die wisst ja dass
ich das schon seit jahren im shop
anbietet und das ist auch das gleiche
was in unserem baklava verarbeitet ist
also wenn ihr das haupt verwendet das
super gerne und dann werde ich in butter
die quasi noch mein hähnchen anbraten
[Musik]
das hähnchen habe ich dann nur 2 minuten
anbraten lassen koriander dazugeben und
auch auf jeden fall salzen und nachdem
zwei maximal drei minuten also es muss
wirklich nicht es ist oder in euro aber
es muss auch nicht gar sein nach diesen
zwei bis drei minuten dann einfach die
gehackten tomaten dazugeben und noch mal
alles richtig ordentlich verrührt seht
ihr unten da ist so die so eine art
kleiner sud also so ein weniger so wurde
ich schon fast sagen und das muss jetzt
ein bisschen einkochen aber wir gehen
jetzt auch schon joghurt mit dazu und
dann kann das alles zusammen wirklich
noch mal so ein bisschen ein kochen das
alles wird so ein bisschen fester und in
der zwischenzeit kochen wir auch schon
mal den reis in salzwasser aber nicht
ganz klar er wird nämlich nur so nicht
haltbar sondern drei viertel gar gekocht
[Musik]
so beim rises diesmal so dass wir nicht
genau das wasser ab sieg dass das
auslaufen kann was er mit übrig bleibt
diesmal lassen wir das einfach richtig
dolle köcheln also auch nicht nur so ein
bisschen dünsten da schaue ich gleich
auf jeden fall für euch auf die uhrzeit
wie lange das premier gebraucht hat und
ich hier zu unserer hinten masse könnt
ihr auf jeden fall auch schon
lorbeerblätter dazugeben und dann warten
einfach bis diese masse auch super selig
wird und voraussichtlich wird das dann
beides gleichzeitig fertig werden und
dann kommt nur noch der allerletzte
schritt und dann ist das gericht auch
schon fertig
[Musik]
unser fleisch musste jetzt doch noch mal
10 15 minuten auf unser reis warten das
ist aber gar nicht schlimm also es ist
eine super sämige masse die flüssigkeit
ist komplett ein reduzierter das ganze
schmeckt jetzt richtig aromatisch und
ich habe zehn männer hat natürlich
wieder häufig diese stehe ich habe in
meiner hand software an und hier ist
einfach nur warme milch und das gebe ich
jetzt einfach hier mit rein und verrührt
das ist auch ganz typisch ich bin sagt
brandt gehört einfach dazu das rundet
das geschmackliche auch nochmal ab das
ist hier noch mal kurz stehen dass ich
das komplett entfalten kann 50 mädchen
und dann nehmen wir uns hier von unserer
fleischmasse quasi noch mal hier den
herbst schon mal ich dir schon mal
runter auf stufe 3 von 9 immer und die
hälfte von der fleischmasse einmal raus
und dann schichten wir das mit dem reis
und zum reiss kommt dann immer jeweils
auch noch safran milch und frische minze
[Musik]
so geschichtet habe ich das jetzt
folgendermassen also eine schicht
hähnchen dann reist dann wieder hähnchen
und mit reis habe ich abgeschlossen
falls ihr den reis ganz unten in den
topf gibt dann habt ihr vieh senat
reiste dann kennt man ja auch von diesem
tag reist auf jeden fall mache ich das
so also ich bevorzugt das so und gleich
nach circa fünf bis maximal zehn minuten
ist auch alles komplett nochmal also der
reise ist komplett gar alles konnte noch
mal richtig schön die aromen entfalten
und damit alles schön vorsichtig
ungerührt wichtig ist dass wir da
wirklich darauf achtet dass sie den reis
so auflockernd hinlegt und nicht so an
drückt oder sowas und ich hab das ganze
mit geschlossenem deckel jetzt und
danach ist das gericht fertig und ihr
könnt euch schmecken lassen wie gesagt
das ist ein super super leckeres sehr
witziges rezept und ich glaube wenn der
hammer gleichkommt durch drehen jetzt
mich gerade nicht da deshalb
verabschiede ich mich zwar an der stelle
aber gleich werdet ihr auf jeden fall
noch mal in hamm see mit dem test
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so leute ich bin jetzt in der kamera und
haben selbst der kamera war ich schon
fertig umgezogen setzte sich mit coach
aber vor der pause stellen kommen was
ich bekommen sie sogar ein unterhemd ich
sehe mich nicht heißt es noch nicht
einmal sondern ich will titel ist
einfach als vizeammann sport und sogar
egal wo wir war bitter für uns ich
probiere gerne meinen pyjama also was
ist jetzt hier gemacht ich war nicht
dabei ich gerade das ist hähnchen
bibiani und ich sage dir wie es ist es
ist eines der leckersten reisgerichte
die hier gemacht haben münchen
chicken salad schicken
ostseeraum
[Musik]
egal ob das ist das was ich immer meine
dass ich noch meine diese wie sie
gewürze eine arabische küche gab es
arabisch persisch iranisch türkisch
kurdisch egal was dies einfach mega
diese diese diese reste sich geführt zu
diesem so die bayern so richtig weiß du
hast was drin und und direkt im mund
knalls wo genau soll ich meine es knallt
es ist nicht nur aber man spürt so ein
bisschen salz und pfeffer sondern ich
möchte sagen die deutsche küche also
deutsche küche mega torten kuchen aber
erstens esse gegner da finde ich so sein
pferd war meistens oder schlecht gemüse
presse dann war es das aber auch aber
arabisch ist noch mal was ganz anderes
müsste man unbedingt probieren also wenn
ihr zu hause viel deutsch kommt dann
sollte sich mit real machen und ihr
wisst ihr was ich meine leute wirklich
mit mega gekauft weil mir gesagt ist
eine handvoll gesetze es ist nicht so
dass man jetzt 1000 märkte abklappern
muss oder ich glaube auch viele trauen
sich treiber ich denke es ist schwer
aber das ist ja die vorstände gekürzt ja
das ist gar nicht schwer wir sind
verliebt schicken
herrschen auch überzeugende kommen
obwohl das aufgewärmt wurde frisch war
das nochmal nummer zwei also toll
aromatisch leute wirklich vor lecker
unbedingt nach mal unbedingt also leute
an alle die jetzt für schwiegermama
kochen stade an ramadan fastet und somit
die familie ist an denen geht es vor
allem wenn ihr das macht eure schwiegen
haben dafür oder zukünftige
[Musik]
[Applaus]